in this era of endless sequels reboots
and reunions no successful screen
property is ever really complete with
television in particular a big finale
doesn't necessarily spell the end
anymore sometimes it's a no-brainer that
an ultra popular original series will
get a spinoff and once it does the
follow up becomes beloved in its own
right but other times audiences fall in
love with a promised spinoff only to see
it fizzle out before it even debuts here
are some of the TV spin-offs that never
quite made it to air How I Met Your dad
How I Met Your Mother attracted millions
of faithful viewers who stuck around for
nine seasons to find out the full story
of how Ted Mosby fell in love with this
kid's mystery mom the finale ended up
disappointing plenty of fans but there
was a chance to wash that bad taste away
with a spin-off that CBS ordered in 2014
How I Met Your dad was to star Greta
Gerwig but CBS was unhappy with the
first pilot and unable to agree on
conditions for a second casting and
rights ownership issues were also later
cited as reasons the network
preemptively pulled the plug the farm in
2012 as the offices final season loomed
NBC execs worked with Rainn Wilson to
develop a potential spin-off centered
around his character Dwight Schrute
entitled the farm it would focus on
Dwight's vegetable farm and
bed-and-breakfast and all the strange
figures in his personal life growing up
with Dwight Mose was not easy
Dwight was obviously the cool one and
Mose was the visionary which left me to
be the comedian unfortunately the
network was unimpressed most of the
scenes shot for the would-be backdoor
pilot made it into an episode of the
offices last season but NBC had already
decided that they wouldn't turn the farm
into a series the office may eventually
return in some form however in late 2017
reports surfaced that NBC was again
considering a way to revive the cult
favorite comedy with a new series
featuring a mix of returning stars and
newcomers Valley Girls The CW's Gossip
Girl was a very successful teen soap
opera brimming with bonkers
lines while also being tongue-in-cheek
at the height of its popularity during
the second season the wheels started
turning on a potential spinoff called
Valley Girls the series would have
launched with the second season episode
of the same name which flashed back to
the teen years of Serena van der
Woodsen's mother Lily as played by
Brittany Snow it was set in 1980s Los
Angeles instead of Gossip Girls Khushi
Diggs on Manhattan's Upper East Side the
cast also featured Krysten Ritter as
Lily's sister along with guest
appearances from no doubt and 80s icon
Andrew McCarthy but shortly before the
season two episode aired the CW quietly
backed away from the spin-off project
Aquaman the long-running superhero
series Smallville followed Clark Kent's
life in the title town before he became
Superman it enjoyed strong viewership
and featured a cavalcade of supporting
characters whose lives and adventures
could potentially be explored further a
season 5 episode featuring Alan Ritchson
as AC curry aka Aquaman inspired a
potential standalone series for the
character with actor Justin Hartley
taking over the role the CW ultimately
declined to pick up the series instead
releasing the pilot as a standalone
feature but it didn't work out so bad
for Hartley as he later joined
Smallville as Oliver Queen aka the Green
Arrow in 2018 Hartley revealed that
there had also been plans for a spin-off
featuring himself as Oliver and Erica
Durance as Lois Lane instead those
characters remained on Smallville while
a separate Green Arrow series later
premiered on the CW in 2012 the
Chatterbox with the possible exception
of steve urkel
no sitcom stars voice has ever been
quite as iconic as Fran Drescher's on
The Nanny she was at once charming and
annoying trashy but still sophisticated
as the show became a hit and introduced
several characters from Fran's past CBS
was ready to consider a spinoff a
backdoor pilot entitled the chatterbox
aired late in the nanny's second season
it took place at Fran's favorite hair
salon and introduced viewers to the new
characters who worked there but despite
some earnest efforts by the would-be
spin-offs cast men
the Chatterbox never made it onto CBS's
scheduled assignment earth there have
been numerous versions of Star Trek over
the years in fact one of the earliest
attempted spin-offs happened near the
beginning of the original series is run
in the second season episode assignment
earth actor Gary Lansing was introduced
as Gary 7 a time hopping alien on a
mission to save humanity with his trusty
cat by his side
record the following plus agents are
found immediately I must undertake that
mission the episode was meant to serve
as a backdoor pilot but the original
series itself was in danger of
cancellation so assignment earth was
never picked up but since then there has
been a seemingly endless number of Star
Trek remixes on the silver small and now
streaming screens so despite this early
setback the franchise has indeed gone on
to live long and prosper
[Music]